there's an interesting world politics
story I want to talk about September
25th the date has been set for a
referendum on the independence of the
Iraqi Kurdistan and that day is getting
closer and closer it's uh just days away
at this point Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu who I am no fan of as
you know I won't restate why most of you
already know that said last week that
Israel supports the creation of an
independent Kurdish State a country for
the Kurds right an independent Kurdistan
and this isn't hugely shocking back in
2004 Benjamin Netanyahu said that the
Kurds deserve their own State so he's
been consistent and it's also not just
Benjamin Netanyahu that has this
position a few days ago Justice Minister
Ayelet shaked said during a conference
at the interdisciplinary center in Hertz
Leah that Israel and countries of the
West have a major interest in the
establishment of the state of Kurdistan
I think that the time has come for the
u.s. to support the process the
connections between Israel and the Kurds
go back about 50 years and in the 1960s
Israel had covert relationships with
some Kurdish factions and there are sort
of some overlaps in ideology as well if
you survey the Kurds compared to other
Iraqis you would see that the Kurds are
way more likely to want separation of
mosque and state right their version of
church and state this is interesting for
a number of reasons number one in one
sense it makes sense that Israel would
support an independent Kurdistan right
there's this shared history of
statelessness as well as of persecution
that was the driving force in the
creation of Israel so that part is
logical and there's another angle as
well Mosul has basically fallen in Iraq
and that's been a big drag down of Isis
in the region if you think about adding
to that Kurdistan as an independent
state it even more fragments the region
and it arguably negatively impacts Iran
as well and you can see the evidence
that Iran is sort of understanding this
because Major General Mohammad Bagheri
who's Iran
Armed Forces General Staff chief has
called this referendum for an
independent kurdistan quote unacceptable
iran doesn't want it and it's very clear
why the leader of Iraq's national wisdom
stream who's amar al Hakim has actually
suggested that Israel itself had a part
in instigating the referendum anybody
surprised right you never want to lose
an opportunity if you are Iran or Iraq
or whoever you never want to lose an
opportunity to say it's actually the
Jews that are behind whatever it is else
it is that's going on and there's a lot
to be debated about how much an
independent Kurdistan would actually
impact Iran but there are those who are
reflectively anti Israeli and they see
Oh Israel supports an independent
Kurdistan and they say well you know why
Israel wants that right they want to
seed chaos and lack of unity among
Israel's enemies of course the other
position which is much less
conspiratorial is that listen having
another official independent entity in
the region that's not openly hostile to
Israel that's just a good thing
regardless of your view on Israeli
foreign policy the Kurds are generally
sort of comparatively secular they
almost completely identify as Muslim but
remember that secular is not a theist
secular refers to separation of religion
and government so there's actually a
pretty obvious alignment between Israel
and an independent Kurdistan certainly
more than what the flat-out Israel
haters are making it out to be and I
find the the discussion of the Kurds to
be a really really interesting one and
we've talked about this on the program
many times before we did an interview a
really good interview actually with
Stephen Mansfield on the YouTube channel
members also would have access to the to
the full show archive it's called can we
trust the Kurds to fight Isis and it was
a story we did I did not have the
highest expectations of how much
attention it would get I thought it was
a really important interview to do with
Stephen Mansfield but the interview has
done incredibly well the issue of the
heards is very interesting there have
been some really good investigative
pieces about the Kurds certainly by 60
minutes I think by maybe PBS Frontline
as well we've covered it and I think
that this is going to be when you think
about the future of the Middle East
there are a number of different sort of
discussions to have Isis what happens in
Egypt what happens in Iran the
israeli-palestinian conflict the
influence of Saudi Arabia but certainly
on the list is the future of an
independent Kurdistan and I encourage
you to check out that interview today's
program is made possible in part by zip
recruiter if you are hiring it's
important to know where you can post
your job to get the best candidates
because it can be pretty tough with zip
recruiter you can post your job to over
a hundred job sites with a single click
they're powerful technology will match
the right people to your job and that's
one of the main differences in terms of
how zip recruiter works unlike other job
sites zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it will find good
candidates for the job you've posted and
in fact 80% of employers who post a job
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the website within the first 24
hours and because of their dashboard you
don't have to juggle emails to your
office you don't have to juggle calls
coming in you can screen rate and manage
all candidates in one place you can find
out today why zip recruiter has been
used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most qualified candidates and get
immediate results right now my listeners
can post jobs on zip recruiter for free
if you go to zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman that's zip recruiter com slash PA
que ma n one more time try zip recruiter
for free at zippers com forward slash
Pakman